[Música]
Estados Unidos extenderá el programa de
reunificación familiar y establecerá
centros de migrantes en Colombia
Guatemala se trata de una de las
estrategias de la Administración vaivén
para enfrentar una posible oleada
migratoria tras el fin del título 42 el
próximo 11 de mayo
el gobierno de Perú acusó a Chile de no
colaborar con la situación migratoria
que genera afectaciones en la frontera
mutua y exhortó al presidente Gabriel
boric a solucionar los problemas el
embajador chileno en Perú fue convocado
en Lima mientras en la zona limítrofe se
registraron choques entre migrantes y
las autoridades Tenemos reporte
acabaron las campañas electorales en
Paraguay de Cara a las elecciones del
domingo los principales candidatos a la
presidencia el oficialista Santiago peña
del partido Colorado y el opositor
Efraín alegre de la concertación
nacional se dieron los últimos baños de
masas en Asunción y capiatá Tenemos
reporte
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos en Estados
Unidos porque el 11 de mayo expira en
este país el título 42 una normativa que
impuso Donald Trump en su presidencia
durante la pandemia para expulsar a
migrantes irregulares en la frontera
alegando razones de salubridad ante el
fin de la regla la Casa Blanca anunció
un nuevo plan que abre nuevas vías
legales para que los latinos puedan
migrar además Washington abrirá nuevos
centros de procesamiento de solicitudes
de asilo en Guatemala y en Colombia
aunque no se detendrán las expulsiones
Rosa Pérez más deu nos cuenta más
no se abrirán las puertas del sueño
americano tras la expiración del título
42 el 11 de mayo
Déjenme ser claro nuestra frontera no
está abierta y no estará abierta después
del 11 de mayo lo que estamos anunciando
es la expansión de nuestro plan para
construir caminos legales e imponer
consecuencias Para quienes no usen esos
Caminos con la incertidumbre de si la
oferta cubrirá la demanda la expansión
de nuevas vías legales anunciadas por la
administración biden se suma a los cupos
habilitados ya a venezolanos cubanos
haitianos y nicaragüenses si tienen un
familiar o patrocinador estadounidense
una política que ahora se abre a
personas de Colombia Guatemala El
Salvador y Honduras por otro lado
Washington abrirá nuevos centros de
procesamiento de solicitudes de asilo y
visados en Guatemala y Colombia e
intentará derivar a migrantes hacia
España y Canadá a pesar de que cuando
caiga el título 42 impuesto por la
administración Trump durante la 19 el
pretexto de amenazas sanitaria no
servirá para justificar las expulsiones
inmediatas de las personas que crucen
irregularmente las fronteras el
secretario de seguridad nacional aclaró
que las devoluciones a México no se
detendrán aquellos que lleguen a nuestra
frontera sin una base legal para
quedarse habrán hecho el camino a menudo
sufriendo traumas y pagando todos sus
ahorros a los traficantes solo para ser
devueltos rápidamente serán expulsados
en cuestión de días o de unas semanas la
restricciones impuestas por el título 42
se levantaron excepcionalmente para los
ucranianos mientras varias ong
denunciaron que a personas de otros
orígenes se les negaba el derecho
internacional al asilo en todo caso la
medida no impidió las cifras récord en
el año fiscal de 2022 cuando las
autoridades de Estados Unidos detuvieron
a más de 2,5 millones de personas que
intentaron llegar al país que recibe más
migrantes internacionales del mundo
cruzando una de las fronteras más
peligrosas del planeta
seguimos en este país y Vamos hasta
Washington allí el expresidente Mike
pence declaró este jueves ante un gran
Jurado Que Investiga los hechos
ocurridos en el asalto al Capitolio el 6
de enero de 2021 pens estuvo más de 7
horas dentro de la corte en la que
testificó luego de que anteriormente
Donald Trump hubiera intentado impedirlo
alegando que las conversaciones de aquel
día están cubiertas por el privilegio
ejecutivo petición desestimada por el
tribunal de apelaciones de Washington su
declaración se da en momentos en los que
considera una posible campaña por la
nominación del partido republicano una
decisión que lo llevaría a enfrentar a
su antiguo jefe en las primarias
vamos a Perú en donde la migración está
en el centro del debate allí comenzaron
este jueves los controles del estado de
emergencia para reducir la entrada
ilegal de migrantes el decreto que
promulgó ayer la presidenta peruana
dinavoluarte se aplica en todas las
regiones fronterizas del país y le
permite a la policía patrullar
conjuntamente con los militares ella
culpó a los migrantes del aumento de la
violencia en Perú por su parte el Primer
Ministro Alberto tarola acusó a chile y
citó textualmente de tirar hacia otro
país su problema con la migración
nuestro corresponsal en Lima Francisco
Zacarías no se amplía
agentes de la policía y miembros del
ejército llegaron a la región de tacna
en la frontera con chile para cumplir el
estado de emergencia por 60 días
ordenado por la presidenta Dina boluarte
y evitar que migrantes ingresen
irregularmente al territorio peruano
horas antes un indeterminado grupo de
ciudadanos de diferentes nacionalidades
tras forzajeos con policías peruanos
cruzó la frontera entre chile y Perú
corriendo hacia territorio inca las
fuerzas del orden devolvieron 86
extranjeros indocumentados hacia la zona
limítrofe el Primer Ministro peruano
Alberto tarola afirmó que no van a
ingresar al país andino ciudadanos que
no estén debidamente registrados y se
tomarán medidas como la expulsión a
pesar que la crisis migratoria los
ánimos entre chile y Perú circulaban en
medio de la cordialidad hasta que
Pascual güiza alcalde de la ciudad
peruana de tacna llamó innombrable e
irresponsable al presidente chileno
Gabriel boric al que acusó de no tomar
medidas adecuadas para atender la
emergencia en paralelo el Primer
Ministro peruano Alberto tarola le pidió
al presidente boric y a los demás
mandatarios que solucionen sus problemas
y no los tiren al Perú el impase motivó
que el canciller de chile Alberto banque
beren cite al embajador de Perú Fernando
rojas para que reciba una nota de
protesta con la molestia del gobierno
chileno Mientras tanto alrededor de 300
ciudadanos extranjeros de diferentes
nacionalidades la mayoría de ellos
venezolanos llevan 14 días varados en el
límite de chile y Perú Esperando poder
cruzar nos vamos ahora hasta Paraguay en
donde este jueves cerraron las campañas
presidenciales de Cara a las elecciones
presidenciales del domingo el
oficialista partido Colorado cerró su
campaña con un acto multitudinario en la
capital Asunción allí habló su candidato
Santiago Peña y alentó a la multitud a
buscar cada voto el domingo para
revalidar la presidencia del desgastado
abdo Benítez
venimos y apoyamos a esta Causa porque
estamos trabajando desde el ámbito de
verdad y queremos la continuación de los
proyectos en lo que el Ministerio de
salud Está trabajando entonces por eso
fuertemente estamos apoyando a Santiago
Peña que todos sabemos que
otros países que quieren influir en la
decisión que tomemos nosotros los
paraguayos es netamente político es por
otras cuestiones a nivel de
latinoamérica
tema de ideología de género y otros
planes que tiene los afuera que quieren
influir en nuestro país entre tanto la
opositora concertación nacional cerró su
Campaña en la ciudad de capiatá unos 20
kilómetros de Asunción Desde allí el
candidato Efraín alegre aseguró que el
domingo harán historia al derrotar al
partido Colorado y comparó a sus
contrincantes con narcotraficantes tanto
él como el resto de locutores los
acusaron de haber robado durante sus
mandatos el domingo unos 4,8 millones de
paraguayos se están llamados a votar por
unos nuevos presidentes y vicepresidente
así como a los integrantes del Congreso
y a otras autoridades locales y en
Argentina la expresidenta Cristina
Fernández ofreció una conferencia en el
teatro argentino de la plata capital de
la provincia de Buenos Aires allí
criticó duramente el acuerdo alcanzado
con el fondo monetario internacional que
según la ex mandataria es inflacionario
y es necesario revisarlo porque según
ella supone un lastre para el país las
palabras llegan en medio de una fuerte
crisis inflacionaria en Argentina con el
precio del dólar Blue el cambio informal
cerca de un valor de 500 pesos por dólar
digo
sigo sosteniendo que ese acuerdo
ese con el fondo monetario
es inflacionario por qué es una política
enlatada
enlatada que se aplica como una receta
monotemática a todos los países
Un gobierno constitucional voló por los
aires cinco presidentes en una semana
muertos en las calles de la ciudad de
Buenos Aires represión miseria dolor
entonces creo que
es necesario
revisar
esas cláusulas
ese acuerdo en Estados Unidos el
controvertido presentador de televisión
Jerry Springer murió a los 79 años en su
casa de Chicago luego de haber sido
diagnosticado con cáncer hace unos meses
su programa de Jerry Springer show se
transmitió hasta 2018 y llegó a tener
más espectadores incluso que otros
míticos programas de Estados Unidos como
el de Oprah winfrey
aquí este informativo se han conectado
esa France 24
[Música]